I have a great book to recommend for you
today it's a book I just finished a
nonfiction book called addiction by
design machine gambling in Las Vegas
it's written by Professor Natasha Dow
shull it is extraordinary and it's based
on 15 years of research that
anthropologists anthropologist Natasha
Dowie shawl did about how not only
casinos but also video poker and video
slot machines are designed to pull
people into these sort of trance-like
states that that are called the machine
zone and I've always been a little bit
interested in the psychology of casinos
and gambling and this is an
extraordinary book from Princeton
University Press that deals with even if
you don't care about gambling like I'm
not a gambler and I don't care that much
about gambling specifically but I'm very
interested in this sort of psychological
considerations that go into not only
planning casinos but also the specifics
of these gambling machines it is a
really really worthwhile book and it
will take you through everything from
the relationship between the addict and
their addiction as well as the
relationship between gamblers and
casinos it has interviews with a problem
gamblers it has interviews with
designers of a lot of the gambling of
machines including video poker and video
slots there's just so much there and
it's such a great book Pat that I'm
going to actually try to get the author
on the program I haven't told her this
yet but she's on my list of people to
reach out to so well-written disturbing
in many ways but incredibly enlightening
topic I don't know if you are a gambler
or not I'm not but the topic is very
interesting to me I would not call
myself a gambler I mean if there's like
a game that involves some sort of skill
like poker or something I can kind of
see that because you have some control
over what the outcome may be but if it's
something like slots where you're just
you know just taking a chance I mean it
seems kind of desperate and I can see
how a lot of people have a problem with
that we know that i think twenty five
percent of revenues
casinos come from addicted gamblers so
it is a big problem according to this
book it's more than twenty-five percent
and that's a really interesting thing
you often hear the casino industry say
hey listen problem gambling is not
really an issue only one to two percent
of the population are problem gamblers
but what that doesn't consider is that a
lot of the population doesn't go to
casinos so a more relevant question is
well what percentage of people that
regularly go to casinos or problem
gamblers the number goes way up and as
Pat is suggesting a significantly a
disproportionately high percentage of
profits Pat cited 25% it may be that it
may be as high as 35 or 40 percent of
casino profits that come from problem
gamblers and the book covers all of this
and more so I really encourage you to
check it out we are talking about the
book addiction by design by Natasha
Dowie Shaw hopefully she'll be joining
us on the show for an interview sooner
than later and you can check out all of
my recommendations at david pakman.com
slash recommendations i'm on twitter at
d pakman the show is on twitter at david
pakman show we really have an
extraordinary program coming up for you
today